you look through all of the supplements  that's been researched over the last 20  or 30 years and there's one that stands  head and shoulders above everyone else  that's caffeine and the reason why  caffeine really improves performance is  because it acts on your central nervous  system and it can reduce the perception  of therefore the optimal dose for  caffeine is you can get a performance  benefit from as little as 2 milligrams  per kilogram body mass so here are 75  kilo athle that equates to 150  milligrams which is kind of in the  ballpark for most of our lighters  actually so we've been working very  closely with science of sports to  develop our SAS athlean shots  that's 150 milligrams this will be  really key for us prior to those real  short sharp efforts especially like time  trial efforts